beef dessert beef dessert
are you still rolling okay jasmine what
are we doing today i just finished
watching a clip from friends where
rachel makes this english trifle and
i've wanted to make this for a very long
time i've been very curious so i did
some research to see how we can make it
we're gonna make it because i want to
find out if it's like a comedy tv show
punchline or if it's the real thing
because joey liked it what's not to like
custard good
jam good meat good
i think i might be a joey and you guys
said you didn't want to try it so i
thought
well we should definitely do it so today
we will be making the thanksgiving
trifle from friends where rachel messes
it up and it's half a trifle half a
shepherd's pie sounds pretty good i'm
excited are you dressed as regenerator i
am you noticed
we are going to start by making the
custard rachel makes it from scratch i
have a saucepan over here i'm just
adding in my milk now i'm going to add a
pinch of salt and my sugar now we're
just going to whisk this together until
the sugar is melted and then we want to
keep this warm we don't want it to come
to a boil so while this is warming i am
going to make my slurry i have some
cornstarch here and i'm just going to
add in my milk i'm gonna whisk this
together so the slurry will help thicken
my custard this is just a very simple
classic custard now we are gonna
separate some eggs let's hope this goes
well or maybe you might catch a racial
moment right on camera
you're very serious right now what
happened am i very serious yes you seem
very very concentrated you got to be
concentrated when you're separating eggs
because
wow
that yolk is so much bigger than the
other one so now i'm whisking up my egg
yolks and then we're going to temper it
with my milk so with tempering the eggs
it just means that you're slowly
bringing up the temperature so it
doesn't cook and become scrambled eggs
because uh that was one of my rachel
mistakes before which is why i don't
think
she really made it from scratch i made
from scratch now i'm adding my eggs my
tempered eggs back into my milk and then
we can move on to the next step so now
that my egg is incorporated now i'm
gonna add in my slurry i'm gonna slowly
whisk this for about five minutes until
it thickens up so the custard is done i
removed it from the heat and now we're
gonna add in my butter and then one
teaspoon of vanilla i think you're a
rachel you think i'm a rachel a little
bit i mean i love her but i just don't
think i am her when we're doing our
taste test i feel like a joey all right
so my custard is done i removed it from
the heat and we're just gonna run this
through a fine mesh strainer so now i'm
covering this baby with saran wrap
making sure to touch the custard to
avoid getting that film on top and then
i'm going to let it cool a little bit
before putting it in the fridge for a
few hours now it's time to saute our
beef peas and onions
be right back
i think this will taste good i have high
hopes so now we're gonna make the beef
part of this
dessert it's supposed to be the
shepherd's pie so this is where rachel
gets it wrong but you know what i think
this mixture is actually not that bad so
i just added a splash of some olive oil
so if you don't know what shepherd's pie
is it's like a meat pie but instead of a
pie it's more like a casserole and then
it's topped with mashed potatoes there's
really nothing to not like about chef's
pie unless you mix it with
ladyfingers
and jam so i'm just going to saute these
onions until they're softened i'm adding
some salt some pepper because why not
all right our onions have softened a
little bit so now we are going to add in
the beef why do you like friends so much
oh
well it's a really good show i really
like it but my mom when she came to
america she would watch friends to learn
english so it has a very special place
in my heart this beef is looking
absolutely lovely now we're just gonna
add in my frozen peas and we're just
gonna fold this in all right this beef
is looking good for our dessert i'm
gonna go gather everything get our
custard and then we can get to
assembling so i have some ladyfingers
first i'm gonna line them along the
bottom now i'm gonna line the side of
the trifle dish our first layer is in
next we are gonna go in with our jam i
put it in a piping bag i'm trying to
replicate the little divots with the jam
i actually don't think that the meat and
jam combo will be that weird jam is in
it's custard time let's go in with this
layer of custard
like take out the beef do you think
you'd like this now
yeah if there was no beef this
undoubtedly would be delicious next
layer the raspberries the raspberries
are to get buried anyway so just making
sure that it has its own layer we're
going to go in with another layer of
ladyfingers and it's time to go in with
the all-star ingredient beef it actually
doesn't look bad now we're going to go
in with another layer
of custard
honestly i feel pretty good about this
recipe i'm not going to lie it's banana
time how do you feel about the banana
meat custard combo
actually it's pretty common to eat
banana with some savory dishes or like
all dishes for some cultures so it's not
actually that weird to me last layer
y'all the whipped topping oh yeah let's
just use the whole thing oh my gosh this
is beautiful yeah
hey
you will eat it and you will like it all
right okay i think we're done i'm gonna
put this in the fridge let it sit for a
few hours let the lady finger soften and
then it's meal time can i get a whoa
first person we're bringing in today is
adrian tasty's production coordinator
and a friend superfan adrian has no idea
this is happening so let's bring them in
i'm going to get adrian adrian
do you want to come taste
some friends yes what shirt are you
wearing how are you doing when you're
ready open your eyes
whoa
you have no idea how much i've wanted to
try this and i know i think i know what
this is the friends thanksgiving trifle
you have three options would you go to
the balcony and a bird takes this would
you go to the bathroom to watch yourself
eat it in the mirror or
would you down it like joey or does it
taste like feet i would definitely watch
myself eat it in the bathroom the
reactions on the tv show was very
accurate here we go you excited
i'm
excited
it what an adventure the end of it
tastes like a burger do i like this okay
katie you have three options i'm gonna
donut like joey i'm shocked kelly you
gotta try this this is one of my
favorite episodes i've ever watched from
friends i've never wanted to try this
though
you got three options you cry yeah i'm
going to the balcony it's going right
over hopefully into a trash can and not
on someone's head but this has to go so
based on everyone's reaction i am taking
away that it's absolutely delicious
it's really good actually it tastes like
french fries in a milkshake i would down
this like joey
i am downing it like jelly i am so happy
i finally got to satisfy my curiosity
after so many years this was actually
really good so i now know for certain
the show is scripted because delicious
as you saw my friends enjoy if you're
curious you guys should make it too take
a picture tag us on instagram what we
want to see thanks guys bye
oh yes
[Music]
you